[Music]
it has been said through the ages
without sacrifice there can be no
victory to species at war one flesh one
methyl Optimus Prime has left us 100
billion trillion planets in the cosmos
[Music]
you know you want to know don't you
something why they keep coming here
I wanna stay
and I want to fight them
now two worlds colliding
the operations over when I keep it up
okay
only one survives
Oh
[Music]
forgive me
[Music]
I'm really glad I got in that car with
you
[Music]
I'm axon transformers partnership
started 10 years ago with the first
transformers and the partnership has
gotten more traction throughout each one
my max gives me the tools to give you
the best cinema experience in the world
transformers has been a giant part of
our brand it helped build IMAX
Michael's pushed us to be more nimble
therefore smaller but not to compromise
resolution he's pushed us for the 3d to
be more seamless he's constantly trying
to surge the filmmaking experience
give me three d8 here on this movie
transformers last night we are shooting
with IMAX 3d and the results are
phenomenal Michael is the very first
filmmaker to take two of these cameras
and configure them on a 3d rig and shoot
in 3d in real time and that's not
trivial the resolution the detail the
clarity
really is mind-boggling we are using all
the IMAX technology to give you the best
experience you will see this year
[Music]
this is the first time we are we're
getting ready to do a big sequence
there's an explosion right here that
pops with those guys under two feet
apart
five cars will be traveling down this
road right here about sixty miles an
hour the first three cars are gonna
panin dangerous but fun my job is to say
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
action Brad I saw Freya in an article
and papers calling it britain's
loneliest dog she has lived in a shelter
her entire life six years no one wanted
her 18,000 people actually saw her
didn't take her I was looking for a dog
and then decided to take her on by which
time Michael Bay had shown interest in
her action I said first of all we'd give
her part transformers no she is working
with Sir Anthony Hopkins her very first
movie and she's done a great job so we
never dreamt of having such a role in
the film
he's a great animal lover and that same
hats off to him giving her this chance
Sir Anthony how's the dog good
[Music]
I've rescued so many and they do love
you more
man's best friends
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you